This video is sponsored by Skillshare.
The first 500 people to use the link in the
description get their first two months free.
Earlier this month, China made history by
becoming the first country to land softly
on the far side of the moon.
What makes this mission especially difficult
is that, unlike those on the near side, this
one never has a direct view of Earth.
To communicate, the rover has to use a special
relay satellite, positioned between them.
But for all that extra work, the Chang'e 4
gives China international recognition.
It’s not just another landing among many.
And this is just the beginning.
In 2017, France spent two billion dollars
on space, Russia, three billion, the European
Space Agency, six, and China, eleven.
And sure, that’s still far less than NASA,
at almost 20 billion,
But the U.S. also spends three times more
on healthcare for the same life expectancy,
so money isn’t everything.
China is also opening up to private space
companies, which quietly compete with those
in America, like SpaceX and Blue Origin.
Spacety, for example, specializes in micro-satellites
weighing as little as 3 pounds each, a previously
unfilled, but profitable, niche.
This rapid increase of Chinese investment
in space will generate thousands of jobs and
countless scientific discoveries.
But it isn’t just about space,
It’s also a calculated, military strategy
with global consequences.
30,000 feet in the air, moving 800 kilometers
per hour, you can watch this very video thanks
to the $260 billion a year industry that is…
satellites.
With them, we can predict the weather, snoop
on our neighbors, and, of course, watch TV.
For free, by the way, if you live in Dish,
Texas, which legally changed its name in 2005
in exchange for 200 free channels.
Could be worse.
But perhaps most important are the 31 satellites
which form the Global Positioning System.
Cargo ships, carrying 90% of the world’s
goods, use it to navigate.
Precision farming makes plowing, planting,
and fertilizing vastly more efficient.
Pilots use it to fly, Surveyors to measure
boundaries, and you and I, to get delivered
the finest Italian cuisine money can buy.
But determining where you are is, arguably,
not even its most important function.
It’s also the world’s clock - keeping
the time for everything from the New York
Stock Exchange, to credit card transactions,
and ATMs, with an accuracy of one billionth
of a second.
Its no exaggeration to call GPS one of the
foundations of the global economy.
So, what does it cost?
Absolutely nothing.
If you’re an American taxpayer, it’s ”included”.
But for everyone else, this $1.4 billion a
year service is provided 100% free.
There’s just one catch: GPS is owned and
operated by the United States Air Force.
Like the internet, it was originally developed
by and only for, the military.
But in 1983, Korean Air flight 007 from Anchorage
to Seoul made a very costly navigation mistake.
Instead of flying around restricted Soviet
airspace, it unintentionally flew over the
Kamchatka peninsula, and on the same day as
a missile test at the same location.
After tracking the aircraft for over an hour,
it was shot down, killing all 269 people on
board.
To prevent this from happening again, President
Reagan made GPS freely available for civilian
use.
And in 2000, President Clinton ended Selective
Availability, granting everyone, not just
the military, access the same level of accuracy.
Officially, quote “It is not the intent
of the U.S. to ever use Selective Availability
again.”,
Which, notably, is not the same as “We can’t
deny access ever again”.
During the war between India and Pakistan
in 1999, the U.S. refused to give India access
to GPS data.
Much more recently, in 2012, a disabled GPS
satellite was blamed for a failed Russia-India
missile test.
That uncertainty is enough to make foreign
countries nervous.
And now consider that this hugely important,
economy-running technology can be interrupted
with a $10 spoofing device.
Because GPS signals are weak by the time they
reach the ground, it’s remarkably easy to
emit a stronger, competing signal.
This device, for example, can trick nearby
cars into going the wrong way or crashing
into other vehicles.
In 2008, Newark airport became the first in
America to use the FAA’s NextGen GPS system
for tracking planes, which frequently, inexplicably
stopped working.
A three-year investigation found a trucker
on the nearby New Jersey Turnpike using a
GPS jammer to stop his employer from tracking
him.
Like the drone which shut down the UK’s
second busiest airport in December, GPS jamming
is so dangerous because it costs so little
to do so much damage.
One, single drone, 100,000 passengers and
760 flights affected.
For all these reasons, several countries are
launching their own alternatives to GPS.
Russia has GLONASS, The EU has Galileo, and
China, Beidou.
Technically, none of these systems are directly
competing.
60% of receivers use at least two of them
simultaneously.
But it’s also in each country’s interest
to control as much navigation as possible.
It’s also part of China’s goal to secure
its claim to the South China Sea.
The problem is, just about everyone is watching,
including the U.S., which routinely sends
ships to patrol the region.
In October, one of them nearly collided with
a Chinese destroyer.
So, the challenge for China is asserting its
claim without risking conflict between 2 nuclear
powers.
Its solution are nicknamed the “little blue
men” - local fishermen sponsored by the
government to work in the area and report
foreign activity to the military.
This way, it asserts its claim, benefits economically,
and does so in a less-threatening way.
But these fishermen have become a target for
nearby countries, like Indonesia.
Which is where Beidou comes in.
Unlike GPS, China’s version allows receivers
to send short messages and request military
assistance.
It gives fishermen the full power of the People’s
Liberation Army without carrying a single
weapon.
This is the tension created by China’s ambitions
in space.
Whether it’s purely motivated by research
and science or not, doesn’t really matter.
Either way, it’s going to be interpreted
aggressively by established powers like the
United States.
Space technology is, at least for now, closely
tied to the military.
It’s just one more way the world will have
to adapt to, or risk escalation with, the
meteoric rise of China.
Investing in space is about exploring the
unknown for the sake of discovering new things.
And Skillshare offers that same kind of feeling
when you learn something new,
Like solving a Rubik’s cube, taught by the
master of learning new things, YouTuber Mike
Boyd,
or let the amazing Thomas Frank teach you
how to be more productive.
Whatever you want to learn - investing, design,
writing, or animation, Skillshare has high-quality
video courses that will help you.
I’ll take a guess and say you enjoy watching
YouTube videos, so why not learn new skills
from those very same YouTubers?
If you’re one of the first 500 people to
sign up with the link in the description,
you’ll get two free months of all the lessons
you could possibly want.
Thanks so much to Skillshare for sponsoring
this video, and to you for watching!